I don't think gaming it's anti-women
like no guy is saying oh you can't play
online today because you're a woman I
don't think it's anti women but I think
there's just a lot more [ __ ] they have
to deal with zapping fighting and
shooting away it's a way of our society
saying come it's okay to shoot what you
are probably wondering is is it turning
their brains to mush my name is Austin -
I'm 20 years old and I play fort night
professionally I won the first really
big fort night tournament it set the
speed for the rest of the scene my name
is Benito nope shot Ian I'm 27 years old
my favorite part about gaming is
literally just winning I'm a very
competitive person I need it just for
chaos my name is Hugo I am 33 and I play
Super Smash Brothers for Dignitas so I
just play it as a kid and I just had a
ton of fun with it but I always wanted
to be better than other people at it I'm
Ariana Gamboa I'm 19 years old and I
play halo competitively it is my passion
and girls can also game one
misconception is how much work people
actually put in there's a lot that goes
into it a lot of people you know have
negative stigmas playing games doing
nothing with his life rather it can be a
quite a healthy outlet and people really
build futures out the game room
[Music]
well I'm sorry can can you give me a
second to think about this this is like
okay okay I only like energy drinks with
alcohol does that affect your gameplay
well I don't drink when I'm playing I
definitely knowledge the health risk
that some energy drinks have but for me
I mean sometimes I'm playing in
four-hour sessions just non-stop having
to play at the top of my game and it
helps out a lot I held it need it
sometimes and for the purpose of
actually performing I think it's great I
don't drink it at all on my off time
because I felt like I was using it as a
crutch I don't have my energy I can't
compete then at a certain point I was
like that's pretty sad like I need to be
training and then trust that not the
energy drink you don't want to rely on
it not gonna lie I need a definition I
worry yeah Oh inside what women okay
gotcha
three
everyone has that experience when
they're in a gaming Lobby and well
probably us females probably experience
this more as soon as we speak we get
called fat we get called all these ugly
names and that is still something I deal
with today as I did 10 15 years ago it
is definitely a terrible thing to
experience I have a girlfriend that
dreams though so I feel like I've gotten
more open-minded about it and
understanding and I can definitely
understand the obstacles like females
have to go through it's pretty tough
from people just saying dumb [ __ ] or
saying you're bad saying you shouldn't
compete or and sometimes hear those
things too but they don't hear it
because they're men you're right right
right they hear it because of whatever
like the internet wants to hate on some
random [ __ ] like we have to prove
ourselves more that's the big difference
I'm a competitor like I don't care about
what my gender is what how much I weigh
I don't care about any of that like if
I'm good enough like then I'm good
enough like I just don't really believe
in that I think it's more so than giving
us a chance or seeing that we're
actually still speaks for itself
no one no guy is saying yeah you cannot
get on the computer because you're a
woman like no guy is saying like oh you
can't play online today because you're a
woman them I kind of disagree with that
and like I do agree that the skills
speaks for itself while anyone can
typically play any game they want and
become good the environment makes it so
that it's much harder to succeed as a
woman than it is as a man there's no
doubt that the experience will be
different
oh yeah the experience is different but
I don't think gaming is anti women I
don't know I don't think it's anti women
but I think there there's just a lot
more [ __ ] they have to deal with so like
back then you know arcades and the first
like home consoles girls and video games
just weren't a thing you know it was
like a boys only Club anytime a girl was
like interested video games guys would
be like oh you know just go play makeup
or go back to the kitchen or something
yeah yeah exactly and it was so dumb and
you know as years gone by gaming culture
has advanced right and it's become more
accessible and diverse unfortunately
they're still you know some people out
there that still treat it like it's the
nineties
video means encouraged by votes I don't
know I don't know because there's crew
wow I just want to like kind of not be
the Wada house so the only reason I want
to say little bit here is because I know
and remembers Columbine like they were
inspired by video games but like it's
just all mental health at the end of the
day I just think anyone who who has
those kinds of issues is gonna find that
inspiration from any kind of medium
including movies including games
including books I even think the
dialogue where you know we act like
that's causing it is kind of harmful for
society in general I think it's
definitely like using video games as
like a scapegoat in my opinion like it's
definitely more of a mental health issue
through video games and violence fake
news it's a myth you know there's a even
music rock-and-roll drugs sex and rock
and roll and the blamed rock once and
then they blame rap and then exactly man
like you know I think on the opposite
side of that spectrum videogames could
even be pointed to the thing where it
could be used as an outlet for the
people that have those kind of urges and
thoughts and it's like an escape exactly
just keep for exactly it's a whole
nother world but I think on the
underlying issue of that I think that
really comes with like the parenting I
mean if you're having those kind of
thoughts in general I mean there's so
many of us that play video games don't
have those kind of thoughts how would it
it's like you're said it's just a
scapegoat
for traditional sports you have to push
your body to such lengths to be able to
do those physical feats to be the best
to be whatever I just don't think that
it's as hard I agree I'm usually like
sitting on my computer for almost 10 to
12 hours a day
physically I'm not doing anything near
and NFL or NBA players do anything I
don't play basketball but I don't think
that they're working on like
frames-per-second kinds of levels of
reaction and speed but then you know not
all sports are as intensive as like
football and like soccer and you
probably all thinking basketball because
it's like it's the mainstream it's tough
you know because there's yeah there's
also but there's also golf there's also
like bowling darts you know and I think
gaming eSports is like as demanding as
those if not beyond that
[Music]
it's hella fun it's competition you know
you're trying to get everyone riled up
you turn out throw everyone off their
game he's waiting for this one yeah
words you know once people start taking
like life problems and wait and try to
like find stuff up on you that's where
it gets petty and it's childish but um
trash-talking is super fun I do it a lot
on stream you know I'd yeah I mean I
love I love trash-talking people it's so
fun if you're doing it in good fun then
I think that trash talk is essential to
any video game honestly builds up hype
yet even if I die or if they die my
go-to is your trash like that's probably
my god see I think I call people [ __ ]
idiots all [ __ ] way too much I always
call people virgins my everything like
you're a [ __ ] virgin but I only say
it on the mic because then you can tell
like you can understand my tone and it's
not that serious but I would never like
type something like that actually I have
a whole like diss track about me like on
YouTube yeah and then my friend just
wrote one back so there's just like I
know that everyone's hyped about it
everyone just yeah yeah
I'll start because I guess I'm a little
older back then it wasn't ever a career
now it's so different like if I were to
tell my parents like yeah hey I have a
401 K from gaming like I have health
insurance I have everything just like a
regular job with like a bachelor's
degree or whatnot so I actually I'm a
little bit younger and my parents were
always super supportive
I quit football and sports when I was in
like seventh grade and I just really
started gaming even after high school my
parents my dad gave me a whole year to
try to do something with it started
making some money and it just took off
from there so my parents were very like
good about it and makes me feel like
proud I mean my parents did the very
similar thing and after I graduated high
school I asked for a chance I was like
hey could I have just a year I want to
really see if I can make this work you
know I want to pursue my dreams and I
won that won the tournament that you
know we both popped off in yeah if this
was three years ago I'd say I'd be over
there saying they'd be skeptical dead I
don't know but my dad's always been
supportive of me and I'm thankful for
that during high school it wasn't really
money in it yet and my parents were just
like no that doesn't sound like a good
idea you're kind of throwing your life
away so then I got a regular career and
then when my friends started making
money and video games I was like what
the [ __ ] am I still doing here they saw
how much happier I was doing this versus
that and they knew I was capable of that
now they're like watching on stream
together like they're showing up to some
live events here and there my mom is
very very supportive of what I do but I
was living with my grandparents for a
while and they actually kicked me out
and were charging me rent because they
didn't see live streaming or competing
in video games as an actual job so I
moved back in with my mom and I got to
quit that job and now I'm living my
dream so I don't have much family I just
have my mom right now and she's an
immigrant and very old school so you can
imagine how she feels about it she
always said you know you're wasting your
time you know I didn't work so hard to
make a family here just so you can play
video games you should make something of
yourself
but ultimately and you know as long as I
was happy with my life and I became
successful in my own definition then she
was okay with it as well
but she still hates gaming yeah we're
your parents right my mother's from the
Philippines my father's from India okay
my parents are Hispanic they definitely
weren't about it initially - they'll
understand it when they see the money
yeah so like you have to make money for
people to realize it's actually a career
yeah you showing the Paycheck they're
like oh so it depends on what you guys
to find us good living I live in Silicon
Valley in the Bay Area the highest cost
of living ever this competitive gaming
career I have is it's a side hustle if I
just did any one of those by itself I
would not make it I used to live in a
trailer with my dad in Ohio so I
understand the struggle you know I used
to sleep on the mattress on a floor
you know gaming I started streaming I
started you know getting a lot of
attention in tournaments I was making a
lot of money there I mean now I live in
like in the really nice part of
California like rent free with my
girlfriend and there's a lot of money to
be made in gaming whether it's streaming
YouTube tournaments sponsorships the
World Cup that was like 30 million like
there's just the reason why I'm not on
stream strongly agree is because it's so
unreliable and inconsistent in my
opinion which is something you have to
worry about and you don't know if you're
gonna place top eight you know most of
the time tournament payouts can take
months I I'd say I make a really good
living I think that fortnight has given
me a lot of opportunities I mean the
viewership and the tournament prize
winnings alone is ridiculous I mean I'm
getting way too much money for just
playing video games to be honest yeah I
play smash Nintendo does not give a [ __ ]
about us so like I still make enough to
like I have a car I have a roof over my
head I got 401 K I got like I'm fine
but I'm not making like like [ __ ] you
money you know I mean like I'm not
making like Fortnite money and so for me
personally it's it's just that's just
the life of the game that I chose if
you're playing for tonight you pick the
right one
yeah I'm sponsored I have benefits I'm
comfortable I'm happy I love what I do
and I not only win money from
tournaments but I'm also contracted so
I'd also point out that you know maybe
our definitions of good living are
different I mean me and Aiden especially
I know that we come from you know not
particularly the best you know living I
mean I used to live in Louisiana back in
like you know middle of nowhere when
nobody would even know where I am my
salary right now is way more than enough
to make a good living off of it but then
again it depends on the area you live in
if you're living over there I mean yeah
like if I lived in Kansas
I'd be filthy rich filthy rich I'd be
like making it rain I'd say I've made
some of my best friends ever and even if
the game is done we've already built a
bond past that where now we're just
friends and none of all these
connections and things that have gone on
wouldn't exist anymore unless I played
this game you know back in high school I
I was like really nervous to talk to
like ladies and I wouldn't I never had
never had a girlfriend in high school
and then after high school I I met my
girlfriend I currently live with so I
think one thing too is people online are
way more open than in person like you
feel a lot more comfortable
never in my life but I think through
just gaming you could meet people that
you can call your brothers and sisters
for life like I have those like I would
die for these people we live around the
country I was like you guys on to go to
Canada you're like sure and we just had
the time of our life and I just met them
online through gaming or at a tournament
I I agree with you guys I mean gaming
has led me to a bunch of events like
twitchcon all these things even this
where I meet people and that's built
those relationships and I think the
gaming I mean I've met everybody through
that know I'm thinking about it pretty
cool
I think so maybe
[Music]